by the time Lincoln finally faced off of
Salman Khan oh he had effectively
undermined South whole network new
Bordeaux belonged to Lincoln as soon as
he broke marcado's hold on a district he
transferred power to one of his under
bosses I'll decide who gets to run the
day-to-day like I said cassandra ran
guns
she was Lincoln's main arms dealer she
could also lean on a few operators at
the telephone exchange Cassandra told me
to reach out
I certainly appreciate some help with
phones one call from Lincoln would cut
communication for whole neighborhood
forget about calling in reinforcements
or reporting on his movements once he
got to organize he had Thomas perk set
up a service that delivered him a
vehicle from his private fleet whenever
he needs them anywhere in the city
day or night was like an armada a couple
of my guys been keeping tabs on him she
talked to them Vito Scaletta was one of
the most connected gangsters in the crew
so he became sort of a mob administrator
Lincoln need a backup muscle once
Coletta's hit squads was never far away
he also had connections to an
underground doctor who gave Lincoln
whatever he needed to patch himself up
thing about Vito was he was old-school
mafia guys like that don't take orders
from some punk who's not even in the
family we got rules not my [ __ ]
problem that you people don't understand
it's one of the great things about
Lincoln clay though he could line even
the most unlikely of allies god damn
don't you want a man like that on your
side I worked in Vietnam and it
definitely worked in Newport Oh if mr.
play had such grave misgivings about his
associates why enlist their help in the
first place you're still not getting it
it was never just about killing mark
honor
it was about hurting him first Lincoln
wanted to take his legacy apart piece by
piece
tear down everything he'd ever worked he
wanted him to understand that with all
his money and all his muscle and his
influence there was nothing he could do
to stop it
Lincoln had a significant impact he did
what the bureau wouldn't couldn't do he
finished them then somewhere along the
line Lincoln realized something you
still can't seem to grasp the best way
to take down an empire to make sure it
stays down is to build another empire
right on top of it in Bordeaux belong to
be anybody left to stand in my way
you